it's that time where we say some dude
there you go yeah we're gonna watch them
the channel supernatural conventions
from our friend ash over at our patreon
page who sometimes puts these videos
together just for us but I think this
one is just for the channel so yeah no
special at renown just wow with you I'm
just messing with you ash love the title
of this one is called point Jared
I don't know if that's gonna be the one
that's in our title for the YouTube
reaction we might think of a better one
yeah joking you'll always be better than
us but of course I'm sure you've heard
us mention this before if you have and
you haven't done so already what are you
waiting for
check us out on our patreon page become
a patron objected a weekly Q&A s and we
do TV show reactions stream alongs when
you sync up with a timecode full link
and those shows that we cover are agents
of shield stranger things season 3
Gotham haunting of Hill House season 1
in Cobra Kai season 2 and their shows we
have the stream along option and we do
edits for reaction highlights included
like when you see a YouTube cut for TV
show reactions we do that for a lot of
the shows that we cover at patreon as
well and those shows are super natural
of course my hero academia movie
included hunter hunter code yes Death
Note attack on Titan
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood and one
punch man and just so you guys know
we've recently updated the way how the
Browse features work on patreon to make
it easier for you guys to navigate our
patreon page especially on mobile
especially on mobile the last thing I'll
mention is in March we will be starting
up reactions that our patreon for Doctor
Who anyway let's get into this
[Music]
shows your statements
where's the first gentleman that works
next worker you know I'm gonna do a lot
about secrets
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I'm actually beyond that I can read
through one fine but very very slowly
three four five six seven times until
they figure out the way that I think it
makes sense to me I'll go on and so
it'll take 40 45 page script is usually
will be a I'll spend an hour to happen
reading that's just a study but I only
do it once and then it just gets locked
in there they want to show it one said
like you said older legalize a few times
and and then we'll go in and perform for
be its leaves it kinda it leaves me
available to allow happy accidents and
all of the little things to kind of
inter system cells there's a lot of
times if I'm reading it I'm studying and
over and over and over and I've seen has
happened with Miss Carr's over come on
they'll read the lines here so much that
they want nearly exactly I don't want to
see how her exactly how they want
is life and no matter what the person is
doing opposite them not react how
they're delivering their lives that were
that would change the way that they
realize they're still saying exactly
going so they're not really even
listening today they're just waiting for
me to stop talking so that they can
deliver their performance and that
wouldn't make sense is what happens if
I'm delivering a different performance
that they have in their head that's what
they were attacked so it in my life you
know over stuff he hasn't been one of my
sannyasis but if you do you overdo it if
you want yourself into that it could be
it could be damaging that you're so
available for the creativity that
happens in the last fourteen years where
we do with our coverage so the sickness
[Music]
we like bring out the best and actors
don't expect emotional basketball to be
ready for it
I think it was we were very years and
years were from season 1 to 2 2 to 3 3 4
even for five advice works into 15 we
were we were always not sure if we were
coming back for the next season now that
doesn't mean that we hadn't done
something that we were proud
anybody that's in there was amber her
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and then I
[Music]
[Music]
back of a truck
we're like restore their equipment he
has a perfectly good trailer right next
door
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes do it
why hasn't I come out do it and a Friday
the 13th yeah our woody Valentine we
they left it open you're part of that we
equal yeah hasn't
[Music]
I'd say that there is it is not that we
were reading stuff more like over there
would never say that I'm just going to
change it it is both the rising price of
chocolate they write incredible stories
and they like might ask about this we do
like shag ass based on trust we chose
that they want the best for our
characters in the show and they trust
that we will perform it's with us that
we can if there's an action in there
that is really on the page that maybe
driver was thinking it but when we get
on as we say on the action physically
and it just doesn't make sense for the
character it doesn't make sense
particular see you like they have
trusted us
those adjustments gets the greater
picture yes Episode II was afraid of
everything yes
[Music]
if there is a there is a certain
difference in if somebody yells jettison
or somebody else be and the difference
is so this is a little bit like you know
yeah that's one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
like aims and our faithful
[Applause]
ah 17 minutes I then feel like seven
that fell short I could watch this for
25 minutes this might not have been the
funniest one they'd be seen from the
supernatural convention so far but I
thought it was probably most interesting
one because they really go a lot into
the process of how they do their work
it's like I like hearing the stories I
like hearing some of the behind the
scenes stuff which of course you know
insinuates a lot of the process I
actually liked hearing especially in the
beginning my favorite part was hearing
about how they do acting and this a big
part of acting is listening and reacting
actually what they're talking about in
terms of coverage like if the cameras on
John and I'm feeding him lines or
something I've met a lot of actors who
have confessed they're not really doing
their best when the cameras are on them
because they're reserving the fuel and
the tank for when the coverage is on
them basically and I don't feel like
that's really a fair thing to do because
I think it's about you know giving to
the other actor being committed being
generous giving is the most important
trait of it all I thought it was really
interesting to hear like yeah they both
have two completely different approaches
to studying breaking down overall
preparation but it sounds like by the
time they get to actually filming for a
scene they do let it all go and they
just stay in the moment and then they
feed off of one another they listen they
react they go with the flow I can see
though the pressure for someone who is a
guest star on a show like a CW show
especially especially when I was younger
I don't know if acting intensives are
like this now but in my younger years
when they would train you for like
network television or Disney Channel
things like that it really was what I
consider the wrong kind of acting style
of you have to say the lines especially
if it's a back and forth dialogue have
you seen you have to say the line
exactly like this there's a difference
between a rhythm and there's a
difference between saying a line a
certain way I noticed that they often
would program actors like you have to
say it like this especially you get so
caught up in your auditioning and then
you go to callback then you go
testing and if for a guest-star you go
through a whole lot of process to become
a guess or or reoccurring role that you
do kind of get robotic and lock down the
way you're saying your words and I
noticed the best actors tend to say the
kind of things that they're actually
saying in this video right here which is
you do all this prep you let it go and
you be in the moment then you feel
you've done all the homework and they
and like life when you're talking with
someone you're just listening responding
and you know you're not prepping how
you're gonna say it exactly to whatever
whatever dialogue you're naturally
having in real life but I think that's
why you know their dialogue is very
super did it we got it we got the joke
in there but yeah it's a good reminder
that scenes really are alive and yeah I
think anybody who's dabbled in acting
has probably gone through that phase of
okay I gotta train myself to see the
line just right one thing from watching
all these you know behind the scenes and
in convention footage is that it seems
like they are a good union for each
other they're not exactly the same and
especially in the prep that was
illustrated by cher is reading the
script like tons and tons of times and
Jensen's just really hyper studying at
the once and it's cool because it
reminds me to that like any type of art
form doesn't have a one specific way to
do it or to prepare for it or to you
know express it you know there are
similar things that everybody has to do
but when it comes right down to it the
goal is ultimately the same thing with
artistic advice especially like things
like acting or whatever writing even
advice is kind of like a buffet you kind
of just take what you like you use what
you can you know to put on that plate it
resonates with you in terms of like what
you're saying we yin and yang their
chemistry on these conventions the best
comparison i got is Robert Downey jr.
and Chris Evans I highly Jensen Ackles
is kind of like the cool dude who
doesn't really laugh at other people's
jokes he was a chill but you know he's
still sincere uh-huh he's like the cool
guy in a different way whereas Jared
Padalecki is a little bit more laid-back
rig areas laughs at everyone's jokes you
know he's goofy little bit more loose
yeah
and sillier every as I compare them is
because like Robert Downey jr. Chris
Evans who still clearly have great
chemistry and love for one another in
these interviews and stuff you could
feel that with these two right here it's
like I can totally see it that even
though the show is ending now but
they're probably gonna stay in touch
they're probably like brothers in real
life especially at this point yeah
spending so much time on set together
and I like the thing they said about how
for like the first two seasons they were
always afraid that it might end so they
would still do their best no matter what
there was like what on average there's
like one season in that early part
that's not 20 so there's like the third
season or something yeah it's like 18 or
17 episodes it's a little bit shorter
but generally they're about 22 to 24
episodes
there's 45 pages in episode you know so
that's months and months off work so the
idea of completing a season it's pretty
impressive and for some reason I never
looked at it in that perspective it's so
easy to judge a show but then when you
look at why they completed a whole
season I can't imagine like what equates
to maybe 24 hours of our time is almost
a year of shooting for them and then
here a post yeah yeah yeah it's it's a
funny reminder of just how TV works and
stuff there are certain things now they
get bought just when they're done like
you know on streaming services Netflix
but for shows like this a lot of the
time you're you're shooting stuff while
you have episodes airing you have your
airing schedule going while you have
your shooting schedule sort of a few
steps ahead of that and there's a lot
that can happen there and yeah and they
talked about getting moved around to
different time slots and that was nice
to hear it an odd way cuz I feel like
that used to happen a whole lot more and
TV than it doesn't now cuz it like he
said it's probably worse now and I think
that's true because there's so much more
content and you see all these shows that
come out and only do one season what's
crazy to me is the show's notoriously
known for having a very low budget yes I
mean you could kind of pick up on that
by the fact that they were always afraid
to cancel they keep moving the time
slots yeah it's known to have a really
low budget if I'm doing my math right
cuz the first season's what 2005 yeah
and we're only on this season for right
now so it's like 2009 2010 somewhere
there and the effects were one
it's pretty crazy to me how for a CW
low-budget show and I see some CW shows
that what are the effects don't look
that great how the effects look pretty
awesome here for for a low-budget series
from a decade ago a lot of credit to the
people there I mean to talk about like
the prosthetics and stuff the
prosthetics are always good the
practical effects are always great but
even like the visual effects the CGI
still holds up in a lot of ways a lot of
times it's still unnerving very
unsettling except when it's Sam's
melting eyeballs like that I hadn't
thought of it in that moment but I've
been through that in the past where you
have like a prosthetic that's glued is
wetting and there's blood - and it's all
dripping in your eyes or burning the
second the second he said he's laying
down and the Sun is on him yes like this
story are gonna be awful I mean even if
he was dealt with like blood
not even a prosthetics but if you're
like to have blood covered on you you're
it's gonna be painful cuz then you'll
get sweaty and you'll get into that
place where the blood doesn't dry and it
doesn't lately wet so you're just like
slimy and sticking to your clothes and
gross and yes I know in the last
convention thing we watched they showed
a little bit of Misha Collins speaking
and I don't really remember what he
comes a remember he comes across like
more charismatic or friendly yeah if
he's not not that he doesn't have his
charm in the show I love this nasty
little character here's to you real I
know it's the line the way he delivered
well John I'm trying make sure people
don't hate on you free my backs riah for
supernaturals a sensitive family I have
apologized on my behalf the people I
would like to see more of me shade than
these as we get further and I would
imagine we will but yeah like especially
their rapport with him I'm curious about
cuz that whole bit where like it seems
like everybody who's you know in the
main cast or the main you know recurring
cast has a certain rapport you know
boisterous sort of brotherly you know
familial vibe going on I don't think
they would make fun of him if they
weren't truly like in
him do you know I think ash was the one
who told me that Misha Collins was only
supposed to be on like a few episodes
but he was so kind of like Aaron Paul
Jesse's situation for Breaking Bad he
was so great that they pretty much made
him a regular I think is officially a
regular now if I'm not mistaken I don't
know don't confirm that in the comments
as of season 15 yeah all right you start
you've low be a spinoff yeah but hey
start that petition
let's get that blade Valentine - yeah
let's do it do it and a Friday the 13th
follow up alright well ash thank you so
much for putting this together guys
subscribe to supernatural convention -
puts a lot of work into these as you can
tell make sure to check us out on our
patreon page where we got all their
gonna die come on patronage I dare you
subscribe click notification bells get
notified whenever we got a video well
want to cover like these videos at least
once a month and last but not least lb
take it away John lb you're an angel in
our eyes like Castillo's eyes yeah and
that's why you know I've only ever seen
your little profile picture and I have a
feeling that if we were to gaze upon
your actual face we would both end up
like Pamela from the show and our eyes
would burn out from your intense glory
so thank you for protecting our vision
for being here for being you for chiming
in on these episodes on the beats yes
but like you have such a wide array of
interests and you bring such joy to our
page so thanks for being here and much
love T of John you successfully rambled
and made it about her I did it did you
study it you finally did it last night i
sat at home and watched 100 of your
shout out there just took meticulous
notes hell yeah John did ladder them
make it about that and I made it about
job